over the last six months
my team and I been all over the country
checking out your best restaurant
nominations and tonight my search
continues with another of the UK's
favorite cuisines ty
[Music]
over the last 10 years Thai food has
taken Britain by storm even the pub's
are doing it now but really top-notch
authentic Thai restaurants are so hard
to find actually chance please
thank you I've eaten some great
restaurants in Thailand and I know that
secret to authentic Thai food it's all
about getting that balance right between
the sweet bitter hot sour salty flavors
tonight's contenders and have to be at
the top of the game to impress me from
hundreds of tiny nominations I've
hand-picked my top two to go
head-to-head for a place in the
semi-finals
[Music]
from son Andrews Scotland's Gulf and
capital it's Nam Jim I just love to
shirred you know how good Thai food is I
just very proud they'll be fighting it
out with a colossal Thai restaurant from
the heart of London mango-tree you are
one son son of a I'm always fired up
I don't need Gordon sticker walking at
me are some day I'm ready nom Jim and
the mango tree will be battling to prove
they have what it takes to be my best
Thai restaurant for the first of three
grueling challenges I've dispatched 30
fervent foodies who descended each
restaurant in turn and order on mass
first stop 50 miles north of Edinburgh
its bonus and Andrews
this town is not only famous for his
golf venue but also Nam gym an amazing
Thai restaurant is run by a dynamic duo
husband and wife
sandy and B and they pride themselves on
cooking authentic Thai cuisine today I'm
expecting nothing less than a hole in
one I'm gonna see anyone's cottage in
the b8 no sorry well husband sorry the
only Scot in the village the first and
only tyrant in st. Andrews nam jim's
charm and authentic cuisine has taken
the town by storm
it just simple but perfect determine -
while the locals bees even created and
inspired signature dish using Scotland's
national fair haggis face spicing it
doesn't actually taste like haggis it's
a buy pork isn't it that's delicious
what I love most about this place is
there Jeff Abby she's burst with energy
she's happy in her cooking I'll stop
happy and it shows in the food amazingly
but you had never cooked professionally
until she and her husband sandy openam
Jim eight years ago successful
businesses all in the detail we kind of
try and be the best we can be we use the
best ingredients from Thailand great
service we just won't do everything as
good as a give it away this is one the
restaurants a huge following of
celebrity golf fans
[Music]
this is my Hall of Fame that's a Tiger
Woods's mother mr. Sean Connery here mr.
Samuel Jackson he just said thank you
very much your food is wonderful I was
so proud
now being Sandy's hard-fought reputation
is about to be tested to his limits
my coach full of hungry diners are just
around the corner all 30 of them will
expect a spotless meal in just two hours
[Music]
I'm gonna be over everything not just
the diamond but in the kitchen as well
and as you know I miss nothing I'll be
spotting everything manager sandy is in
charge of keeping all my 30 diners happy
penes team must explain these unique
Thai dishes one of the house
specialities is the Thais Scottish
haggis we also make that with a
vegetarian haggis which is essentially
pulses and nuts pea
the orders are starting to roll now yeah
yeah as well as the haggis B's menu
includes vegetarian jungle curry and
tamarind up with Pak Choi as fast as
front-of-house send the orders through
being her efficient type of guide on
knocking out amazing food Thai cuisine
it's quick it's not a long-winded style
of cooking is done in a very fresh and
sort of rapid way sandy the only bread
on the team is the all-important link
between the dining room and the kitchen
are you at your weakest in here when
they're speaking fluent I just kind of
ignore what they're talking about like
to see kind of what they're doing more
than anything
so long it's a really weather of machine
it's not a race to me the standards far
more important okay if the starters are
anything to go by the standards don't
seem to be a problem later on fire but
at his hectic pace it's vital that every
member of the team is on top of every
detail this is the vegetarian wool sandy
stop stop stop
cocoa cream there's no coconut cream on
their nose mother before you take
anything you gotta tell her self-control
here isn't it you're taking dishes she
doesn't know is John one lamb cutlets as
well guys and that's all the start has
done for everybody then sandy things all
the starters are out but a quick scan of
the dining room reveals he's missed a
whole table how sandy are you missing an
order all the tables are taken here as
front of house boss sandy should be all
over this so that's that's all gone no
that's all gone
yeah smells nice
contest to see threes as opposed to see
two and you don't help Amazon you take
food don't tell her where it's got it
I'm just the fly in the ointment okay at
last the missing table get their food
okay man cost me at all breathe whilst
bees kitchen ramps up for the mains
Sandy's front-of-house team seemed more
and more disorientated
we've got more waiters in here now than
we have chefs do you know we're going
sandy sandy looks a little bit so lost
there yeah you know but he comes in a
little bit yeah okay so like this we
just like to like to be out right away
so you handle pressure better than he
does
despite his confusion Sandy's got nearly
all the main courses and desserts out
with 45 minutes to spare
and it's soon clear how he's done it
she's eating her - ser while I'm having
my me pork I don't think we expected
that when we ordered it you know woman
you ordered I thought you start together
I'm sure it's best to serve the starter
yeah cap main course cap and then
dessert but we thought rather than
somebody sit there eating what the
partner has nothing for 20 minutes it
was less you know for somebody to be
eating at the same time I know that's
personally how I would prefer it it does
make sense no I agree I'm seen it so far
in the competition today being a kitchen
team really have scored a hole-in-one I
went for the tie vegetarian highness
which was really exquisite the food was
fantastic start to finish it was
delicious renal socks off worth waiting
for
with such fantastic food the wheat link
here is clearly front-of-house I spoken
to the diners and not everybody enjoyed
having their dessert and the main course
at the same time dessert is a sort of
sweet grand finale not to be eaten
opposite a duck the saving grace today
is that everyone loved the food that's
for me the most important tine up get
the service as good as a food in 99
percent of the way there
my best restaurant hit squad of 30
diners are on their way to the second
toy restaurant battling for semi-final
place in my nationwide competition
just a stone's throw from Buckingham
Palace is one of the most popular toy
westerns in the capital
it's mango-tree to be here big
destruction knock has been front of
house manager of this huge 160 seat
restaurant since it opened 10 years ago
I love manga 3 it's my baby this is my
life my inspiration even the kitchen is
huge as well how are you so nice to see
a Englishman heading a Thai Kitchen way
from I'm planning you have Thailand
thank God for that
hey check marks passion for Asian
cuisine led him to work in Vietnamese
and Japanese kitchens before coming to
the mango tree
what we're trying to create is the
essence of the Thai Street food served
in an eloquent way is accomplished take
on Thai cuisine attracts 350 diners at
night on a busy weekend by star
restaurant I really enjoy coming here is
one of those places you can really trust
for mark controlling such a vast
operation is made harder by a less than
ideal restaurant layout with the kitchen
and dining room on different floors all
the food is sent by left these earpieces
things like someone from the secret
police to coordinate food and service
staff use radio headsets and if all else
fails there's always the phone
yes coming right now when a customer
happy when a staff happy I am very proud
what I'm doing with knots battalion of
waiters and Mars Revere's food this huge
restaurant should find my first test at
Donald
[Music]
but every ration I've tested so far has
struggle with my coach load of 30 dinars
arriving in ordering all at once they'll
expect every dish to be cooked to
perfection
[Music]
I want my diners to leave tonight you
know on cloud nine I want their jaws on
the floor really push it out yeah and
good luck we got a new order to me
income one chickens are tight we're just
going to do what we do best and that's
the quality and the consistency of the
food you don't want to be complacent if
they're thirsty pad thai there'll be 30
great pad thai it's that simple
mark has hand-picked a small selection
of his most popular dishes for my guests
tonight including shrimp Tom Yum chicken
satay and tiger prawn pad thai
he's taking these Thai classics to a new
level of sophistication with truly
authentic flavors and exquisite
presentation but upstairs front of house
of discoveries made a big mistake
I know approach I for this time all of
the dish in here can be substitute to
which carrion is not probably the soul
you don't need to worry about it
knocks professionalism has carved a
potential mutiny
meanwhile the fish and meat eaters are
loving their starters useful flavors
complement each other amazing I would
definitely recommend but there's a
serious problem with one diners chicken
satay the chicken Kurtis is seems quite
fleshy inside and quite pink it's
absolutely yes I
[Music]
waking up [ __ ] that we drank it will
take another 5-10 minutes I'm sure you
don't expect it from the top restaurant
to ask my food to be sent back to the
kitchen new order one chicken satay well
done overall your leave them both the
chicken satay starter and the baby
chicken main course a half cooked free
service and finished off to order by
kamyshev Nielsen on this occasion he's
got it badly wrong heavy part cooks the
chicken you want expected to go out no
he's very annoying when we're dealing
with the people that we are dealing with
tonight
Mart's been quick to send up a
replacement dish but I want to see how
well this lift system works in my
restaurants I can bark orders at my
waiters over the pass but here every
dish that leaves the kitchen must travel
up two flights of stairs by dumbwaiter
- Mikey is his job to send the food to
the right table what was that although
should tell you what table is before
they send the [ __ ] thing though yeah
don't know never what is coming in the
legs I can only guess seeing the foot
and Perrier to the ticket ok not they
selling food but no one's told me what
table in terms of ticket for this one
yeah so just set their diet
please come on yes there's always like
this yeah [ __ ] me that's 430 kimochi was
like was what 300
everything in the lift send it as
service ramps up the system is falling
apart
oh it sees the main it is yes we wait
but most of the mistakes are picked up
by the waiting staff before they hit
their dining room what's wrong with that
you say nowt wrong so I need I need this
instead okay send it down then what's
that right it's not missing oh I don't
get a ticket for a Gaia but I go what
table is it set it down to you this is
crazy
what a mess
lots of great food don't know where fast
so if you send me again table 38 they
would take it they got the main cause
already that lift is busier than [ __ ]
Paris he own his knickers yes dad this
list could be a nemesis you'll be given
absolute total pain in the ass he
doesn't know what he's selling up there
it leaves here immaculate it goes up in
the lift they grab it out it pisses down
the side those diners are gonna get
pissed off for that to me it's nothing
short of a miracle that all 30 diners
eventually received the correct food all
loops lovely beautiful worth waiting for
I'm in heaven I'm in heaven but it seems
once again this tables got a problem
with that food it's undercooked after
the earlier talk up with the undercooked
chicken starter unbelievably it happened
again this is to cook pasta sorry I said
let me just take it back I'm always
afraid to kill you just yeah on the bone
just [ __ ] Diane come back walk mark is
on the warpath how's it possible huh
you know check any of them I mean look
you're [ __ ] pre-cooking them is it
that hard Libby wants to eat raw chicken
you huh
to my horror the true scale of the
chicken scandal is only just unfolding
definitely rule yeah just this one that
is to tell one more voice no problems
the same again now what
two more portion of chicken so they take
a make sure it's well done this time
what's on that one it's the same time
same terror yes there it is
he's wrong I think yeah the thighs roll
yeah
this is the last thing I expected from
this incredible restaurant hf mark looks
as shocked as me this is what was
talking about quality in the consistency
I'm the one who looks at Fran
something that's almost renders it oh
wait - firing there's two two tables but
kind of messed it up fingers crossed for
this one this pieces of carrot it's
stunning it's really really good it's
it's a very big difference from the last
place I got it's a credit to knock in
the front of house team that the
majority of Medina seemed unaffected by
the Kaos service is amazing so everybody
good they're really accommodating when I
said I didn't like spicy food and stuff
the part I was really because there was
a problem with the menu in the
vegetarian our particular waiter has
been absolutely wonderful with us really
attentive they take a great interest and
to our experience here the military in
the end most of my diner seemed happy
but p'march
has been one of the toughest nights of
his career right west restarts I know
what you're capable of you only have to
read the comments - why this freshman is
in this competition and the support
you've got from customers is phenomenal
then we're done is arrived and
unfortunately they haven't had that same
experience that's where it hurts for me
come back and come back strong - nice
[Music]
throw all that away throw it all the way
sick of looking at every time something
isn't right you know I didn't take it
very personally there's no reflection
that our team can't cook situations do
happen sometimes it's how you rectify
them is the most important thing and
hopefully they they don't happen again
[Music]
[Music]
nom Jim and the mango tree have survived
the coast trip now I want to meet up to
review their performances or so they
think
they have no idea I've been spying on
them with the help of undercover diners
who've been filming secretly Simon Davis
is a professional secret diner with an
eagle eye for weak spots in restaurant
food and service
sarah Durden Roberson is a top food
consultant who's been expertly
dissecting menus food and service for
years I've asked them both to be
demanding to see how the restaurants
responding
this is just a bit too spicy for me
could i order the chicken I'd really
like to have that but I will get this
one first up is knob Jim and the Mamba
have to show them a front of house for
Yasko that no one is prepared for
unknown to both of you I sent in a
secret diner that's very cool and this
is what he saw
good evening I've got a table booked to
name Duncan that's the Thai haggis
thank you very much that hang is it's a
creative idea to farm that invented the
spice levels perfectly pitched it's the
sort of thing that could set this
restaurant a car from other Thai
restaurants in the country
actually loved it and that kind of wow
factor my god so chai glasses up the
whites apply white a dear I just try a
little bit I know I've never had Thai
wine before the other one it's gonna be
like you know what am I gonna do with
the photos okay could we bring a bottle
what if it's not very nice wine I won't
want to drink it wow that's not how we
offer one service is it something no
that's a bit of a shock sorry yeah okay
okay
I do like that I don't think I do like
that's actually yeah I know but I told
him if I didn't like it I wouldn't have
it that weight actually looked looked at
me no way would he behave like that if
you were there Sunday I think not what
more likely to do would be probably to
come and ask what to do about the
situation dad it's not ideal it is
appalling
I'm just shot through honesty
you know it's wanted more I told you
before over well I'm not paying for it
oh yeah I basically say what anytime
call the police
basically I think before if they have
gone in a minute I ask for a glass of
Thai wine okay um you know you gonna let
me speak and you give me the evil eye
and you say to me I'm gonna you have to
pay for that wine and then and then it
and then you say to me if you don't pay
for that one I'm gonna go and call the
police you call that decent service dude
I'll pay for it but I mean that's just
absurd that ranks as about the most
aggressive service I've ever seen in my
life oh my god
I'll call the police
I'm lost for words incredible
what I would love to is I'll put out an
olive branch to the manager
he takes it we kind of kiss and make up
figuratively speaking me excuse me
hi there what's happening with the wine
I didn't you know this visit with the
police I thought it was very you
shouldn't have bread to pillow you could
see in his face he knew you shouldn't be
sandy how does it make you feel when you
see that style of service been running
your business out
yeah I'm both shocked very embarrassed
and more than a little bit hungry I've
all that's been a very energizing
experience many levels I'm enthusiastic
and excited about the quality of the
food service has been smiling courteous
off in the one blip and I'm leaving here
thinking I would definitely come back
here and I would tell people about it
and they're the two things that when you
were restaurant over you really want
your diners to me
some night Wow
you will be corrected that will never
happen again obviously the gentleman
Asst has come away with a decent
experience apart from that one blip as
he called it but to be honest it's
difficult for me to look beyond that
blip
everything you did is perfect I'm upset
and I think it's a combination of being
very excited and very happy and then one
minute and anchoring the complete
opposite end of the spectrum you're next
and you know so I the minute I think I'm
just a little bit lost for words I'm
just very for someone to point out
updates you know because of the best
service and then the thing is not it's
not that not what we want our customers
come first in everything I hope we
haven't blown our chances within the
competition
[Music]
we're gonna have to work hard
tonight two amazing restaurants are
going head-to-head in a competition to
find my best restaurant in Britain
you wanna teach some young girl
[Applause]
now it's the turn of London's Thai
culinary giant mango tree to get the spy
treatment how are you are you well
welcome we've actually been tested twice
because since I've left the mango tree I
sent in my secret diners and here's what
they saw on the coach trip head chef
mark was crestfallen when undercooked
chicken was sent back to the kitchen
manager NOx supervision kept them on
site but how do they do when I'm not
watching plank on my table
they've got all these plastic wiped
clean covers but they never wipe them
clean it's got food cakes all over it
it's nothing more disappointing first
touch the menu dirty nutgrass noodle
salad is so spicy so anywhere I could
have it but just a bit less spicy Wow
Wow fantastic that was really close
they've brought someone who saw
separately in case I want to control my
own measurement that's exactly what you
should do exactly well handles great
when somebody says they want something a
certain way we don't understand what
their less spicy is sure so it gives
them the opportunity to to do that
themselves oh it was handed brilliantly
it's not very relaxing a fact that I
don't know what they do there's someone
going on the back tables calling it's
serving mats from under the cutlery so
every table he doesn't screw ching ching
ching every time they do it I feel like
I've overstayed my up and they're trying
to steer the tables would you please get
out now
I feel like saying I'm terribly sorry am
I in your way what a shame when they
feel that awkward and the noise is
ridiculous especially you're trying to
eat dinner food complain about a couple
of things sent them back they
conveniently dealt with it but their
customer care is pretty shockingly bad
it's neither one thing nor the other
they care and they don't care food
delicious second to none but that
attention detail of the service worked
out for everybody
you forget that sometimes when you're
doing such big numbers so don't take
your personally take it professionally
absolutely it was interesting yeah he's
a bit of an eye-opener what we saw on
the film he's upsetting if I were
customer I I would I would say the same
so I'm very disappointed I don't feel
let down by the service because we are a
team we take the Pat's on the back
together but we take the knocks together
as well and we will fix it there is more
to the competition and we don't want
this to be the end for us both restrooms
have been left reeling by these
revelations but there's still everything
to play for for their final battle and
bringing the chef's face to face in my
flagship restaurant I've challenged each
chef to create one amazing dish for 20
yes but to guarantee a place in the
semi-finals will have to be the finest
dish of their lives his dream so he was
very very proud if we win that would be
brilliant
it was our customers that first where we
are a speaks volumes that they're proud
of what we're doing everything is
focused on today and winning
right huge pressure test this one to
cook 20 stunning dishes make them taste
absolutely delicious
create that level of perfection sadly
one of you believe in competition and
one of you we go through to the
semi-final make sure it's you good luck
beau freshens will be attempting to
impress me with a dish made from chicken
the perfect meat to complement the heady
aromatic herbs and spices used in Thai
cooking both the mango tree unarm Jim
have had their ups and downs and I'm
hoping that they pull that aside and
they focus on those 20 dishes and use
that as they come back outside a dining
room full of VIPs all with a passion for
Thai food will help me judge both dishes
tonight including Thai cookie writer or
a cheap choice ara and one of my
all-time favorite Thai chefs patria wear
a pen all the front of how teams can do
is wait and hope
an order two covers away Table three the
mango tree two baby chicken chef for
mango tree head chef Marc is sticking
his neck out with a new complex dish
made from the baby chickens that almost
brought him on the coast trip he was
gutted when undercooked chicken was sent
out three times
cooked enough I just hope he knows what
he's doing today I'm happy with that
lovely flavor beautiful smell you're
quite fond of baby chicken aren't you I
am
we've changed it obviously when we've
done it in the restaurant we've learned
from our mistakes of you know making
sure it cooks it's why I wanted to do it
because I'm not gonna run away from
anything good very balls for that baby
chicken back on the menu again master
suppose don't eater them him or not so
it's pure focus phenom Jim I'm worried
that be still shaken by my secret diners
bombshell being in here foreign kitchen
I'll know it I don't want this to affect
the quality of a dish first of all I
want to clear something really important
that's gone the wine I want you to set
that completely behind you today is
about you and your food and then show me
that passion yeah tonight be sticking to
what she does best authentic food packed
with flavor marinated chicken with pan
fried oyster mushrooms and a punchy
basil puree
but to elevate this dish to my
restaurants three mission star standards
she needs to be completely on the ball
before rise please be serviced please
tell us it's come on guys the food's
hanging around too long but he's making
simple mistakes all right now please now
I'm Jim - chicken feet you don't even
listen something after that it's two
more not four more you've got four
chicken in there so - I'll take two
chicken out be after this is only two
more you got four in the pan so what do
you take two hours
these lack of focus is beginning to
worry me I need to see her really step
up to the mark okay that's the last year
the moment rushing let's focus on the
service B yeah let's focus on these yeah
B she's had a rocky ride up into this
stage I want that to be put behind her
and just focus on the 20 plates and come
back but come back strong
so this place level six is quick a
pleasure thank you
I'm so nervous about me me getting there
let's go let's go let's go let's go it's
been a struggle but she's got the food
out
so is pleased much better yeah well then
be good job
thank you Joe please dish we try will be
fun aren't you enjoy the chicken it's
very subtle and the sauce is beautiful
it lovely aroma but presentation I'm not
quite quite confident I thought this
dish was excellent our please chicken
disaster mark is determined every piece
will be cooked to perfection today hon
please mark for portions table 2 in 3
minutes piece final touch is to grill it
to turn the skin a delicious
golden-brown mark your dish is it
supposed to be crispy the skin when he
looks any food I don't want it to come
across is burn
first table table five please Germany
happy with that mark I know what does
that fragrance again Jasmine yes very
nice
mark has gone the extra mile honey's
food looks wonderful face number five
Vicki so exciting about it from the
mango tree you can see from my face this
is Wow Excel for me the finishing line
is within sight when the unthinkable
happens
I'm just a bit disappointed cuz actually
as you can see this has not really
cooked let me show it to the chef okay I
mean it'll be taken away for you took
double six feet service I need you to
not have any with this chef they said
their chicken is under cuts
where's the under our [ __ ] line
there's their last I can come off the
bone there you see it clear as day [ __ ]
me
[ __ ] damn I was so pissed off
pink chicken comes back again and if
there was ever time not to serve it is
right now not good enough for more mark
please how long just give me terms I can
tell the time you'll agree minute three
minutes of Table one please tell Rob
don't worry rather leg yeah [ __ ] the leg
pretty pissed off they treat my own
words I'm not happy
Marc you checked all them see them
underneath as well yeah yeah go tell one
pleasure
and I could never have guessed servers
would end like this for mango tree
it's been a challenging night for
everyone
but it's time to find out what my
diner's thought on both dishes starting
with mango tree let's talk chicken while
ours wasn't cooked no well that was a
ridiculous mistake my apologies it just
wasn't even leaving the Bommel day it
was probably still clucking fortunately
not all my diners had the same
experience it's so great when it came
yes and when we tasted it their hopes go
right through it
I preferred the mango tree because I
loved the chicken on the bone it kept it
really moist very very tasty
and the broth with it just worked lovely
all I had to go for 19 because I like
this song so much is beautifully
marinated subtle and then you've got the
sauces complement creation phenom Jim
yes and she carries it lovely but the
rice is bit too much water I mean you
know your rice now I face a very
difficult choice which one of these two
restaurants should go through to the
semi-finals
for Gordon Ramsay to say you the best
that is meant a lot I will never forget
it neither restaurant has been without
fault but even good restaurants have
their bad days
I'm obviously hoping at the other 19
dishes make a bigger impact and
impression than the one but can I
forgive mark for under cooking chicken
again
by two top tie contenders nom Jim and
mango tree have completed a lower biting
service in my flagship restaurant
both chefs to produce an incredible dish
but both have fallen short of perfection
now I have to choose which restaurant is
truly deserving of a place in the
semi-final
but first I need to make my own judgment
on both dishes
[Music]
now Jim it looks slightly clumsy
chickens delicious it's got that nice
crispy texture of the outside you spare
that sauce on top of that chicken the
whole thing just comes alive not eye
catching but math walking and taste
mango-tree have gone the extra mile and
it looks like he's been done with great
finesse flair lovely the broth is almost
like a sort of Tom Yum Goong there's
like two dishes in one rice soft fluffy
and concurrently fragrant nice little
spray on the end with that jasmine
really nice chickens delicious I'm just
slightly nervous about that soft chewy
skin should be crispy - remarkable Thai
restaurants
but only one can continue through to the
next round
okay right I brought both Russians here
to give you an opportunity a unique
opportunity to really cook like you've
never cooked before
now I'm Jim I saw the dish it didn't
look the most appetizing having been to
your restaurant and seen the style in
which you deliver food it was a little
bit of a surprise to see something so
basic as that I tasted the chicken and
bang it was just yeah it was amazing
however at this station the competition
this round is not won on a single dish
now Jim secret diners no experienced
food like that absolutely loved that
food haggis in a Thai restaurant doesn't
even sound right but for you to turn
into something that goes very few
Russians can do that anywhere
my good streak the fascinating thing
with you Mars you're not even you know
in from Thailand you seem to have this
magic with Thai cuisine that is a is a
gift and with mango trees at its best
is untouchable it's ending our secret
diner absolutely blown away with that
food I mean really really blown away
with that food to do the boots that
began at this stage of the competition I
admire the balls
it was sweet it was delicious and
authentic how could I criticize that how
could I look at that dish and tell you
how to do it better I didn't have to the
first time this competition I just came
back
you've left with a very tough decision
[Music]
the restaurant going through to the
semi-final is
[Music]
nom Jim congratulations
[Music]
well done yes whoo - Tommy
why don't you with your touch and the
man experience you have with Thai
cuisine I know you've got more coming
very disappointed you know I'm cycling
hard and north and the team and our
customers down but you know that's the
way it goes you know which man came all
the luck pissed off at the moment
someone never told me before I'm good
and I'm into this competition so it
means so much for me it's a bit
mind-boggling first we were all very
very proud and a little bit shops and
stunned I think
[Applause]
what an amazing day and two great
restaurants I'll be sorry to say goodbye
to mango tree but the same hand we've
opened the door to something quite
magical
Vincent Andrews because they are a force
to be reckoned with but for Nam gym now
the competition really starts because
the next stage of this competition it's
gonna be even tougher